my name is Jason Berg and I'm the
director of Alakazam
and we here at the historical festival
and now you're friends with Sal in real
life how was that wearing sort of two
hats being his friend but then also
directing the film I mean that's that's
actually a great question it was tough
because I had to kind of go back and
forth and figure out how deep I wanted
to get in and
you know I think I'm gonna tell a story
from you know from my point of view and
him being my friend you know I had
access to get the answers questions and
other people might not have so I had to
kind of like play that line like how do
I get and I just decided to go for it
story the film premiered at Tribeca is
that right okay yeah anyone come up to
you afterwards and say hey you know what
I grew up without a dad and it's really
touched me the most epic part about
being a time back other than that
Christian festival it was the people
that came up to you after the interview
was amazing like I've done a lot of work
in the past for a living
when someone comes up and you're like I
love this story I love this part about
it that part about it they really kind
of like different it wasn't just like
how he had a good movie I want to say hi
it was like this is why I love it I was
blown away
guy with the camera from doing this film
does this give a new meaning to what a
father represents for those who haven't
grown up without a dad I know I didn't
so it's like a weird thing when that is
missing from you has this given you a
new take on sort of what fatherhood is
and how important it is no I just I love
those kinds of stories whether they're
good or they're bad because in this
movie there's the distance in there
they come together full circle just love
to own those theories
I like tearing at the heartstrings but
for a good reason making people feel
good at the end having them identify
with things new parts of South story
become other people now Ben Lyons is the
co-host tonight the wonderful Ben lines
how did he come on to the project as
producer right yeah I mean banished to
Venice again this is a family project
and Ben's a part of the family
he have a lot of great ideas to us
especially at post
you know there's just you when you do
projects it's so personal like this that
nobody's funding them you know it's just
us but you gotta bring as many eggs that
you trust together and Ben was one of
those it's a part of our family we're
all fun to have and lastly what do you
want people to take away from the film
if anything or is it just a portrait of
someone's life and in a very touching
story it's a portrait of someone's life
but I think I think I want people to
take away from it whatever part that
they connect I feel like there's
different parts of the story different
verticals in the story that a lot of
people can not
looks like happens that time period I'm
handing a toast or looking forward
seeing it